The term professional dress means
different things for different people
and it also means different things
depending on the environment that you
work in. Some work environments are
relatively formal. They may want you to
wear slacks or a tie and other work
environments may be relatively casual.
It may be casual Friday every day of the
week. The goal is to find the right
balance between what the organization
expects and what you want to wear to
work every day. The goal is to match
what the organization would like
everyone to wear, and that makes
everyone feel comfortable when they're
at work. At your place of work, there
may be designations or professional
titles associated with individuals. And
it's important to recognize those titles
and be able to use them properly during
the workday. For example, it's not
unusual for someone who has spent years
working towards a PhD to prefer being
referred to as a doctor. It's also
important to treat people with the
respect that they deserve and to make
sure that you are abiding by whatever
rules are set aside in your organization
to maintain this level of
professionalism. Instead of being
judgmental towards people's knowledge of
technology or how they're using an
application, your job should be more of
a teacher. You have the ability to make
people more aware and more comfortable
with the technologies that they use
every day. And that ultimately makes
their job better and your job better. We
also don't want to be judgmental because
eventually we will be the one making a
mistake and we want to be sure that
people treat us with the same
professionalism that hopefully we
provide to them.
There's always a time for socializing in
our off hours and on breaks, but usually
when you're at work is a time to be
professional. We want to be on time to
work and avoid any type of distractions.
This includes personal calls, texting
from your phone, and scrolling through
social media sites. Everybody in the
organization has a series of tasks that
they're responsible for and we have to
make sure that we are focused on those
tasks during the workday. There will
certainly be a time when an urgent call
comes through that you have to take in
front of a customer. But if you ask the
customer if it's okay to take the call
and then apologize afterwards for taking
time away and distracting from your job
is an important part of maintaining
professionalism. As a technologist, I'd
like to be approachable for the people
that need my assistance. So, I tend to
keep a bowl of candy at my desk so that
people will stop by and be more
encouraged to have a conversation. And
if I do need to have a conversation with
a customer, I want to be sure that I'm
in an area with no background noise. And
you should always refrain from being on
a speaker phone when talking with a
customer.
When technical problems occur, the
situations can sometimes be very tense.
Emotions can run high, and sometimes
people may say things they don't really
mean. Your goal as a technologist is of
course to resolve the problem, but you
also have to work through these
interpersonal relationships that we have
when one of these issues occurs. We
should never get into an argument where
we're being defensive about the things
people are asking of us. The goal is to
be a partner in solving this problem and
not to contradict each other during the
process. It's remarkable how much you
can do when you simply sit back and
listen to what people are telling you
about a particular technical issue. Not
only does this allow someone to vent
about this very frustrating problem, it
also creates a better relationship
between you and your customers. These
problems may also take place over a
number of days or number of weeks. So,
it's always useful to check in from time
to time and make sure that the customer
knows that we are still working towards
a resolution. And although many
organizations already have rules about
posting information on social media, you
should always think about keeping your
business work private and not putting
any of that information on a public
forum.
When you work in a company, you almost
always are running across some type of
sensitive information. And if you work
in the IT department, you're probably
seeing more of this type of information
than anybody else in the organization.
We have access to data and information
that simply is not used in other parts
of the company. And often this
information is private and contains
sensitive data. As a technologist,
you've been trusted with this very
personal and sensitive information. So
you should make sure that you're able to
maintain a level of professionalism,
especially when it comes to keeping
information private. Ultimately, you
should treat people the same way that
you would like to be treated yourself.
This creates an environment where there
is professionalism and trust among
everyone in the organization.